einen tag lang bewertungen raten fürs
heutige video an wir uns etwas
besonderes überlegt denn manchmal falsch
zum wettbewerb und zum schlechten werten
schreibt meine eigenen bewertung aber
ich habe mich noch nie darin selbst
geprüft wie gut ich eigentlich
einschätzen kann neben transport
bewertet ist und dementsprechend hat
eric sich heute drei verschiedene
restaurants ausgesucht werden drei mal
essen gehen frühstück abendessen und ich
muss erraten wie welches restaurant
bewertet ist so einfach so simpel aber
es wird jede menge spaß machen denn auch
ihr könnt mit raten als erstes werden
wir erst mal gucken wie ist das
aufgebaut und sie die karte aus und
schmeckt das essen dann ist das für mich
vertrauen und dann überlegen uns wie das
ganze bewertet ist fangen wir an mit dem
frühstück kaffee walter ist auf jeden
fall was neues so überhaupt nicht zu
wissen was abgeht was erwartet danke
dass ihr auf dem channel hier
stattfinden da ja geil k4 weiter also
von außen schon mal sehr gut aussieht
schilliger aus brügge lage hast du heute
so eine spezielle strategie wie du
vorgehen will oder ich lass es einfach
nicht wirkung ich probiere das und ich
denke aber auch welche leute das café
anspricht und wie die bewährten wird
dass wir uns einfach hier einfach masken
auch
da sind wir und der erste blick geht
heute immer auf die karte ok akzeptieren
wollte bog ein cache erster eindruck
dass nichts verrücktes relativ basic
alles was für mich schon mal dafür
spricht dass die bin ich in der lage mit
der karte stehen dass sie es gut machen
aber ich habe es ausprobiert ist wenig
zu vorstellen auch so diese hält die
welt
dafür werden wir jetzt gerade versucht
ja alles zu analysieren ja ruhig mal
dass hinten und
kubanische publikum schön gestylt innen
wie außen einfach das schöne ecke auch
oder jetzt geht es erst mal das essen
auszutesten den kaffee natürlich für
mich gern die apfel symbol service auch
mal ein thema was und die meisten
bewertungen mit einfließt es geht um
alles heute es geht komplett entgeht
umlage design karte es halt immer im
hinterkopf es gibt auch restaurants die
auf dem ersten blick gut erscheinen die
aber online nicht gut bewertet sind weil
irgendwelche leute da einfach da kann ja
jeder seine meinung äußern deswegen
kommst hier nicht rein es gibt ja auch
ein café was dann zum beispiel nur
dreieinhalb sterne hat das ist weil so
viele leute nicht rein können ich glaube
hier und erstmal fast hier weißt du
nicht wir sind an wochentag sehr früh
hier neben jung so ist das wäre eure
einschätzung erik pipp ich habe mich
wohl hier seht ihr hier habe die karte
gerade so was denkt ihr mit model anja
[Musik]
special
die schweiz ist für essen checks oder
kommt wie schön dass jetzt diese
abzuschöpfen die karamellisiert sind der
honig aus wohnt kann oder
[Musik]
nicht das ist so perfekt obwohl in
diesem setting ich sagen ob die zeigen
sich heute auch sowie das alles was von
ihrer besten seite also wir sind auf
jeden fall zum perfekten zeitpunkt gibt
es muss wieder darüber nachdenken und
wie ist das wenn leute nicht dieses
glück kam noch alles perfekt saß draußen
sitzen zu lassen
aber vielleicht ist es ja immer so
vielleicht ist auch immer so aber ich
war jeder hat man so seine guten und
schlechten tage trotzdem durch erst das
jetzt auch und tragen werde ich mich mit
meiner finalen bewährt es endlich fertig
getränke sind leer ich kann wirklich gar
nichts sagen zunächst im service nicht
so lage mich zum essen ist alles super
gewesen also für mich ist das gefilmt 15
punkte so kann ich wirklich nicht ich
kann ich kann nichts anderes sagen aber
ich weiß dass es menschen gibt die
wahrscheinlichste ist mit fire die
schlechten tag hatten die aufgabe auf
uns wirken ist es quasi unmöglich 5,0 zu
haben ich werde das nachschauen ich sage
aber es ist mehr an der fünf in der
allgemeinheit meinung als an der firmen
halten wenn es von dem was ich heute
erlebt habe du musst dich jetzt
einloggen
es hat 55
55 war doch klar aber und nur 25
bewertungen crazy mit nachkommastellen
gesagt 4,8 weil ich schon davon ausgehen
dass leute sagen das nicht so gut für
mich hab's gesehen zwei wunderbare
freundschaft mit so hat sich nicht von
deinem ersten gefühl täuschen dürfen so
ist das mittagessen der laden zudem
jetzt gehen heißt austria massimo ist
mir genauso unbekannten der frühstücks
bord und sieht aber von außen
italienisch
von daher
erster eindruck von innen sehr
authentisch das witzigste daran ist ich
weiß selber nicht mal welche bewertungen
die hat hier noch mal gesehen ja ja ich
bin ich quasi hier vorbei gelobt dann
kann es ja diesmal mit mir überlegen wo
gehst du nicht wieder in meinem kopf
frei du bist mit mehreren zu erkennen
vergesst die kamera in so einer riesigen
glasschüssel alter das sehr gut
wir sehen so was vorbeigehen und darf
mir so das sieht sehr sehr geil aus
pasta e basta basta klassiker
sind hier gelandet
ich komme auch das ist so diese
römischen wölfe mit dem modus also so
wichtigen termin vom ersten eindruck
auch auf jeden fall deutlich besser und
hände platziert aber wie geht es jetzt
herauszufinden bewertungen sagt
jahrhundert über das essen aus hier gut
ist sondern ganz viele faktoren zählen
damit die müssen halt auch mit fabian
die bestellen und dann gucken wir mal
wie das ganze auf dem teller aus
[Musik]
hier
wieso das hier so dass hier das ist
genau das spiel und kriegen von diesem
jahr ist es egal ob die ecke ab oder was
auch immer du kriegst hier wirklich
glaube ich krasses essen zu fairen
preisen und der laden ist voll und wir
haben nicht nur drinnen voll draußen
toll und wir können uns jetzt als erstes
natürlich die vorspeise donatoren auch
sehr lecker mag ich sehr sehr gerne ein
klassisches dem was du beim echten
italiener
das super super kräftig das
innovations- größe alter die kursleiter
du das und die passt dann kommst du mich
mal wenn über
dieser speck geschmack das gehäuse
gekommen und kann
also ich akzeptiere keine andere meinung
des films seien gerade nachgeschaut
leute vier sterne ich will jeden
einzelnen verprügelt
wird warte ich guck mal nach wie wir
sind ja immer auf tut mal auf google
maps jetzt nach weil ich akzeptiere das
mitmacht kann man darin aussetzen preis
service essen ambiente also ok maker
sind verschiedene auf 4,4 tätig ist also
wir haben vielleicht auch wieder einen
krassen spot erwischt man muss dazu
sagen eric hat mir verraten er wollte
gestern reservieren zehn mal angerufen
oder so und ohne erfolg so dass
fachleute vielleicht ab aber ansonsten
da gab es nichts trinkt hat wieder nicht
also bis jetzt noch nicht richtig
geraten aber also ist war beides mal so
gut ihr habt ja auch gesehen wie geil
das so aussagen sorgt sie muss mehr in
bewertungen denken nicht einfach nur das
essen ja aber es ist ja auch wirklich so
dass wir beide male nichts einfällt was
man kritisieren könnte klar dass da
jetzt sagen können wo es nicht unfassbar
schick oder so aber das ist doch der
charme so das ist doch die kategorien
dem das spiel das verstehen nicht alle
abendessen und eric hat etwas heraus
gesucht das ist ultra schwer
herauszufinden wie es bewertet ist aber
es ist ultra ultra gehen currywurst also
erstmal alle berliner institut für das
kann nicht gut sein und sagt aber
weltmeister heißt das dass gibt voll
häufig in köln ist immer so rothe häuser
dazu curry 36 aus köln auf jeden fall
der erste currywurst setzen und
überlegen weil wir das bewertet neujahr
am lagerfeuer ein rot weißes rechteck
idee aber es ist ultras werden weil da
auf junge bewertung zu und ich finde
gerade auch das bild was ich hier
gesehen so ein bild was ich ganz
überlegen
war selbst wichtig es ist so kein bock
immer auf so sterne sachen zu essen ja
sehr privilegierte aussage aber ja ich
meine ja aber kann man wirklich hier
rissen die am lagerfeuer
man kann in die bewertung mit einfließen
und auch die kitchen konzerns lagerfeuer
panorama
märz legt offen wie radikal respekt und
dann schauen wir mal überlege ich mal
währenddessen videos bewertet sein
könnte ich will zimmermann gerade sogar
entweder sicher das wird unser gut
schmecken aber ich kann wieder nur so
abstruse verkettung von gedanken erahnen
wie leute das bewerben können du musst
ja vorstellen hier an so einer ecke da
kommen besoffene leute rein alle kommen
bekommt student jeder jeder kommt hier
rein und jeder hat seine meinung und und
hat auch was zu sagen ja wir bevor wir
hier weiter uns schon verliehen bevor
wir
am ersten büro mit dave gemeinsamen
direkt unten im haus weltmeister richtig
finde vor allem die soße gerade sehr
geil
ich schwör's tierhäute frühstück mittag
und abendessen war perfekt es ist ich
würde dem ganzen genau jetzt wieder für
mich eine fünf geben aber ich bin
schlauer geworden ich weiß es gibt keine
5 da soll ich zumindest bei den ersten
beiden bewerbungen merkt ich glaube auch
genau gemeint das ist unterschiedlich
ist es ist es lang wie die anderen
firmen halten ich glaube es sind 4,0
beziehungsweise könnten auch einfach mal
kannst du musst dich entscheiden nichts
machen wieder weil ich selbst einfach
liebe skype in 4 03
23 der gab jetzt noch
was soll ich sagen
vorher ob das 1 2 wirklich übel slacker
es war ein geiles experiment und wird
sagen wir sehen uns gleich im studio
wieder freunde ich hätte nicht gedacht
dass ich zwei von drei so falsch habe
aber es ist einfach wirklich nicht so
einfach sich in die anderen
hineinzuversetzen dann ist es so
unterschiedlich zu welcher tageszeit und
du da bist wie viel hunger du hast alles
alles kommt zusammen und ist auf jeden
fall lustiges gedanken spielt wäre würde
das ja auch immer machen wir gern die
kommentare ob ihr besser gemacht als ich
aber gehe dann aber irgendwohin es dort
und überlegt wie ist das bewährte sind
schaut dann erst die vielen dank fürs
zuschauen auf jeden fall wir sehen uns
beim nächsten mal wieder bisher